una pelota atada a una cuerda oscila en
un círculo horizontal con una rapidez
constante como se muestra a continuación
la cuerda forma un ángulo teta con la
horizontal cuál opción muestra todas las
fuerzas que actúan sobre la pelota pausa
en el vídeo y traten de encontrar la
opción correcta resolvamos esto juntos
esta pelota está atada a una cuerda está
colgando y me parece razonable decir que
esto se encuentra en un planeta por lo
que una fuerza de gravedad está actuando
sobre la pelota dibujamos el vector de
la fuerza de gravedad en color
anaranjado la denotamos con una letra f
mayúscula y un subíndice g minúscula que
es lo que evita que esta pelota acelere
hacia abajo y también que mantiene a
esta pelota en este movimiento circular
uniforme la respuesta a ambas preguntas
es la tensión en la cuerda recuerden que
la atención es una fuerza que jala y
esta cuerda está jalando a la pelota
vamos a dibujar la fuerza de tensión más
o menos así con esto construimos un
diagrama de cuerpo libre y ya podemos
responder la pregunta cuáles son las
fuerzas que están actuando sobre la
pelota
hay una fuerza hacia abajo y hay otra
fuerza con la misma dirección de la
cuerda al ver las opciones
vemos que la primera opción tiene estas
fuerzas pero quizá ustedes se pregunten
acaso no hay alguna fuerza centrípeta
que hace que la pelota se mueva en
círculo y evita que salga disparada en
línea recta y también no hay alguna
fuerza que equilibre la fuerza de
gravedad la respuesta es sí pero esas
fuerzas son componentes de la fuerza de
tensión si vemos el componente x de la
atención que dibujamos en color azul
oscuro es la fuerza centrípeta o mejor
dicho la magnitud de la componente x de
la tensión es igual a la magnitud de la
fuerza centrípeta si dibujamos la
componente de la tensión es lo que va a
contrarrestar o equilibrar la fuerza de
gravedad y la magnitud de esta fuerza ft
jeff es igual a la magnitud de la fuerza
de gravedad ya habíamos encontrado la
respuesta correcta pero con esto
comprendemos mejor lo que ocurre aquí
nos vemos en otro vídeo